good um so i was at a wedding this past
weekend and it's funny you mentioned it
you took the words right out of my mouth
but okay
i was talking to this guy who was
praising happy wife happy life
and next to him was his wife and she's
literally this
she looked like a hippo like she was
this fat round woman
blonde looked like one of those wannabe
desperate housewives she was like really
super tan lots of makeup
had rings on every finger
and i'm just thinking to myself this and
then i found out later on from someone
someone at the wedding that this guy is
worth over two million dollars
and i'm thinking myself how could you
make that much money and still have no
options whatsoever like yeah yeah well
hey listen you know that's like
guys
you know when you've been fed a steady
diet of [ __ ] in your entire life and
um you know not standing up to women and
putting women up on a pedestal um a
hippopotamus can look good to you right
you know if that's what you get then
that's what you get right
he literally he literally told me the
best advice he got from his father
was to always say yes to everything your
wife says
because after the fight you're gonna end
up giving in to her to make up anyway
yeah that doesn't drive in my world man
no not at all and that's why i was
alright i'm this conversation is done
after this guy gets up because
like this is ridiculous yeah it's it's
very common it it's it's more uncommon
for guys like us to have these
conversations and then that's when
people start calling us misogynists or
who hurt you or you know why don't you
like women it's like
bro you know you tell yourself whatever
you want that makes you sleep good at
night but at the end of the day i know
that my life is way better than yours
and i would not trade my life for yours
at all so thanks for your exact opinion
right
right and i had one question though uh
yeah so at the wedding uh i was there
with my girlfriend i've been with my
girlfriend for like two years
and she's the oldest and she has two
younger sisters and the the wedding we
were at was for her youngest sister
so like the whole time i'm trying to be
a good boyfriend we're at the wedding
being nice to everybody
and
her aunts her uncles her cousins they're
all when are you two gonna get hitched
yeah it was so freaking annoying it was
like the entire time it was always
somebody asking
and i get to the point where i actually
got mad at my girlfriend and i said if
one more person asked me i'm going back
to the hotel room like this is
ridiculous
like another one of my favorites you
know beyond that too is when they're
like oh you're so lucky to have her
right that's when i always like bat back
i'm like no dude she's she's really very
lucky to have me in fact exactly so i
was just curious like because you you
know you want to play nice i've known
these people for two years some of them
are good people i push back man you know
like my thing is to push back so when
somebody's you know like i gave that
example of oh like you're so lucky to
have her sort of thing i'm like no she's
actually lucky to have me bro and i and
i say it in all seriousness because i
truthfully believe it right
um so like the stuff like like when are
you two gonna get hitched like if you
don't want to get married and just say i
don't have any immediate plans thanks
for asking [ __ ] off well yeah i just
slap and a lot of them are drunk too so
i just kept saying i'll take it under
advisement i'll take it under advisement
you can always use amuse and mastery you
know stuff like that like oh yeah so i
can get married and be miserable like
you too
it's just i mean i couldn't get over how
many people said it like once or twice i
kind of just left it off but
i'm 33.
and my girlfriend's 20
uh 27. yeah so yeah so like she's
getting
look yeah she's she's in the family's
doing the right thing they're like
trying to get her locked down because i
know and she inherently knows that you
know she's running out of eggs and like
her value in the sexual marketplace is
not as high as a 23 year old right
so i mean if you want to have kids and
she's a good woman and you vetted her
for a few years
have the kids but [ __ ] the marriage part
forget inviting the state in your house
and all that other that's just my
opinion i mean i mean kids are great if
you can raise them together and you can
lead the family but like one of the
points that i'm making with this podcast
guys is that's incredibly hard if you
live in the west you sound like you live
in northeastern united states jersey i'm
in boston boston okay yeah so like
you're like a conventionally sound and
masculine dude right but all of society
is all just shut up do the right thing
man up put a ring on her finger
and then you know if you don't have
frame if you don't have a woman that
doesn't have like
does
like
does your girlfriend agree with about 90
of your morals and values well see
that's what's so funny is like i've
literally converted her because when i
first met her she was a hashtag boss
girl to the core right and i don't get
along with her two sisters at all
because they're everything that you just
talked about in a negative way
so i've done a really good job last year
and a half or so converting her into not
thinking that way but every time she's
around her family it's like starting
over again because you know how it is
with girlfriends vibing and family
vibing and they they all have that
mindset the father has the mindset so
it's like
like i want it to work and she's she
when we're alone we we have no problems
like she's in my frame i just listen to
what i say
it goes that way all a lot but every
time it's the family's a problem because
it's just and i actually told her that
one time i'm like you know
we're gonna have to get to the point
where you're gonna have to pick a side
and it's either gonna be me or your
family because
i'm not gonna change into their way and
if you're not willing to go full speed
into mine we're gonna have a problem is
she super tight into her family values
oh she loves i mean she's
and madly in love with him she praises
her parents yeah and and which is normal
which is like a good sign right you know
like you want a chick that's got a good
relationship but
yeah it sounds like her dad's a bit of a
pushover
um it sounds they all drank and her
parents were both virgins they lost
their virginity to each other
you know she comes from that kind of
home so yeah like but i mean she wasn't
a virgin when you met her though right
she still she told me her notch count
was five but i know you're a double at
score yeah i don't know where to go so
but you know she's she's a good girl
she's a christian girl so she did her
grandfather's a pastor
so she doesn't have a lot of good
qualities
um but she's also got her
framed degree in mahogany and all that
[ __ ] too so
okay so she's one of those professionals
eh exactly she's a she's a professional
teacher a master's degree yeah well look
man you're you're
you're basically talking about inviting
a
female into your life that that that is
drunk on the kool-aid that i was talking
about earlier
you know she's going to enter your frame
she's going to agree with you on 90 of
the [ __ ] but
if if conflict
arises i can tell you what's going to
happen chicks like that they go right to
their friends and family and then
they're like
why did you do this
and they start chirping in her ear and
she's like yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
she comes back to you and she goes yo
tracy um i was talking to my family and
it's like you know you
you're back to square one right so right
exactly like
if i'm being honest
have fun better date her you know do
whatever you want but
like
unless she's
totally in your frame then you've got to
be super careful with chicks because
they're covert feminists right like they
i'm sure she's pretty i mean you don't
sound like a guy that would date a
hippopotamus because you define it no
she's very pretty very pretty yeah she's
very feminine she wears makeup and all
that
um it's just
like like i said i mean she's like she's
she's potentially 10 10 to 12 years away
from an extra 50 pounds in short purple
hair and you know going to marches and
holding up signs and getting mad about
you know whatever the trending thing is
sort of stuff so you've got to make sure
that you know the frame control is there
that that she agrees and supports with
your direction and she's always going to
defer to that i mean you'd obviously if
you're a stand-up guy never do anything
to like cross your family but at the
same time i have no trouble standing up
to anybody like i get into it with
people all the time that are within my
family or in-laws and it's just like no
you're absolutely wrong and i don't
agree with that and that's a stupid
conversation and then almost all the
time they just back off they're just
like you know what i don't want to go
there with you it's like cool because
i'm not stopping so you better shut up
yeah
yeah no i i mean i've gotten into it
with her her sister's like a year
younger than her and she's flat out told
me to my face that men are the inferior
sex yeah
you know it's just stuff like that and
then i i i i'm caught in a rock and a
hard place at that point because it's
like well that's when you cut up salt
you know my girl's sister but at the
same time that's when you come at him
with like you know well what would
happen if guys took uh i don't know two
weeks off and all went on vacation
toilets wouldn't flush electricity would
work stop lights wouldn't work there'd
be nobody at a police crime fires would
never be put out by firefighters so just
shut the [ __ ] up exactly with your
nonsense is basically the way that you
are ridiculous it's funny when she said
that i said oh well let's arm wrestle
right now yeah and we'll see who's the
strongest dad you're so dominant
[Laughter]
good one of course you didn't want that
but all right tracy i got to run again
all right get a bunch more of these
thanks for having me thank you i
appreciate it see you buddy
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
alpha.com forward slash shop when you
click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you